sous la douche et douchez
le boulevard saint-laurent fermée à la
circulation les commerçants sont ravis
les fous la cour et les touristes aussi
des groupes entiers qui vient de voir
des artistes à l'oeuvre c'est le
festival murale bonne partie en fait des
muralistes qui font partie du festival
murales sont les articles qui des
artistes qui proviennent du café tea
narcisse qui ont fait le qui ont fait
leurs bases qui ont fait leur
apprentissage dans la zone dans le
mouvement graffiti et qui maintenant
réussi à l'articuler de façon différente
pour faire des oeuvres qui se rapproche
davantage des beaux-arts mais de façon
et gigantesque ça c'est gigantesque
une immense murale peinte à l'arrière
d'un édifice de la rue saint denis au
perche est une étoile montante dans le
domaine
l'américain tristan eaton 40 ans qui vit
à los angeles
justement dès l'adolescence au tristan
itunes a fait son apprentissage dans le
monde souterrain du graffiti pour en
revenir ensuite à la murale regardez par
exemple ce parking d'une banque jadis ce
déprimant
aujourd'hui on y trouve cette murale
peut être en 2014
sept autres illustrant rue dupuis
printemps 2016 et une troisième a ajouté
l'année dernière il y a maintenant près
de 100 murale dans le quartier dont la
célèbre muraille de leonard cohen pinte
l'an dernier qui a beaucoup de succès
auprès des touristes
l'art mural est accessible acceptable
même désir et les festivals d'art mural
apparaissent partout sur la planète
c'est à la mode absolument oui parce que
les gens voient que non seulement ça
semble un quartier ça aussi stimuler
l'économie
ça va créer du tourisme et puis
évidemment un certain point mais ça va
gentrifié aussi certains secteurs aux
roses la valeur foncière hausse des
taxes la ville guy môquet quand même il
y aurait pour effet d effacement là qui
sont très positifs autant économiquement
que le tourisme en aussi culturellement
qui aurait prédit qu'on ferait la file
pour participer à un événement mondain
autour d'une exposition inspirée des
arts de la rue il faut dire que
l'artiste c'est un des maîtres dans le
domaine il s'appelle banques si un
britannique d'une quarantaine d'années
qui a cette particularité d'avoir réussi
à toujours demeurer anonyme
steve reich commissaire de l'expo a été
la jante banques si pendant 12 ans il
rappelle comment l'origine bank ci a été
forcé à l'anonymat dans sa ville
d'origine
bristow l'exposition présente 80 oeuvres
que banksy a réalisé pour être montré à
l'intérieur et qui appartiennent à des
collectionneurs privés
une expo en passant que banks in n'a pas
autorisé on y retrouve des versions
d'oeuvres connues comme la fillette au
ballon ou encore cette interprétation
urbain de la photo de soldats qui plante
le drapeau américain à hiroshima banques
s'y est beaucoup plus connu pour son
travail à l'extérieur
on voit ici de rares images de lui au
travail à la barrière de séparation
israélienne une de ses nombreuses
oeuvres en israël cette fillette qui
s'élève au-dessus de la barrière avec
ses ballons le message de banksy a très
souvent une touche contestataires mais
en utilisant une forme douce plutôt que
cru aujourd'hui chez les jeunes
muraliste graffiteurs le désir de
contestation serait moins présent
déplore l'ancien agent de banksy
il ya toujours ce danger de perte
d'authenticité
quand un art souterrain devient un art
de masse et c'est là le conseil de
tristan nitot nos jeunes graffiteurs
malgré l'appel de la gloire et de
l'argent il faut rester soi-même
défendre ses propres valeurs des leçons
de vie qui comme l'art urbain peuvent
commencer à s'apprendre des ce jeune âge